all right good afternoon councillors
staff members of the press and zoom
attendees welcome along to this meeting
of the performance policy and
partnerships committee
um i have an apology from councillor
pottinger and we also acknowledge both
councillor abbott the birthday boy and
mrs coote are attending on zoom would
somebody like to move that councillor
pottinger's apology
he's in christchurch yes yes i think he
had a conversation with him he did too
that's been moved by councillor lewis
seconded councillor
put that all in favor
against
carrie no
items in the public forums we've got the
minutes of performance policy and
partnerships from june 14.
somebody wants to move those as to
incorrect reverend cook and councillor
crackit
your matters are rising
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
proposed road name for the kennington
waimatura road
anybody speaking to that
michael
thank you chair
i've got two reports up which are both
in in connection to the road um
the road naming policy uh both of these
reports uh in
in accordance with the policy
and that is the new policy that we have
adopted
as as council
so
i'll take both reports as read and open
for any questions thank you councillors
any questions
reverend cop
um three years to check i thought that
we were supposed to see
three alternatives
and i only see
one name for each place
um is that that the officers see three
alternatives and then put the preferred
one to us or are we i thought we were to
see the alternative
but that might be my misunderstanding
through self-chair
the policy is that three will go through
the offices and
if they are suitable will end up coming
through to council with the preferred
name as the um
cool one but the
in this case there would have been one
in the first one and in the second one
there are two that were rejected as part
of that process so there was only one
preferred name and one eligible name
that came through
thank you very much mr chair thanks good
question
i'll take them uh separately we'll deal
first of all with the kent and wymator
road the recommendation is that
two right of ways be named dairy away in
brunswick way
somebody want to move that
i'll move that way
council of soap and secretary councillor
edmondson questions or comments
put the motion all in favor aye aye
against
carried which brings us to macquarie
street being renamed the road being
renamed named scully place
it's the remover for that councillor
amundsen secondary councillor kit
questions and comments
thrown on i'll put the motion all in
favor
against
carried
customer compliancy strategic framework
jonathan
welcome along
cure
so
i'll take the report as read but i'm
happy to answer any questions
counselors there are two recommendations
as a part of to get discussion underway
would somebody like to move those
councillor scouts seconded by reverend
cook open for questions
consider land speed record
don't want to get too excited
lindsey what was your record
i'll slow down you can't say that i can
read lips if there are no questions i'll
put the motion all in favor
sorry councillor crack at my apologies
quite trivial question i remember we
used to have the well we've got the vade
model now it used to be evade what did
the e stand for
educate what's that engage
i would say
it was also
enforce and educate competition yeah
that then that's the four a's but yeah
it used to be evade yeah
yeah
it's it is kind of irrelevant well not
irrelevant but it's it's not going to be
material to the
uh report or to the decision but i was
just trying to remember what they used
to stand for good question
it'll save on ink
sorry that's a burt monroe oh it was
interesting
there are no questions uh or comments
other than that then i'll put the motion
all in favor
against carried like he escaped jonathan
thank you
which brings us clear to the
pre-election report
yes mr chairman i've ask that it be on
the agenda for your information only and
indeed in the hope that the as a result
of it being put on the
uh agenda that the media would see it
and use it as an opportunity to promote
um the election after all as our deputy
returning officer has been quoted as
saying
these are the wheels of democracy and we
need people to engage to make it really
work well for us
i guess one of the um
the points and and commenting on it
clear is that
if somebody was interested in putting
themselves forward
for at the next election
reading this report is essential
because
you you can't go on on
hearsay or just you know
an enthusiasm um going in with some
information is really useful and a state
of the play at the end of the term
and the pre-election report
is there
so the recommendations are that the
report is received and
we've received the report for
information
of councillor councillor lewis
comments
what's that i just want to sorry how
um good it is to see that we're actually
using
um
the format that we use for the annual
plan and
so that people are becoming familiar
with
the roadmap all those different things
we're picking it up we're reiterating it
we're updating it where it's necessary
and i think that as part of our
engagement and communication with the
community
consistency is really important but so
is clarity and i think this is both
so thank
you thank you for that
any other comments counselor cricket
thank you council alado i also think
that it's fantastic like obviously we we
sit in this room and we
partake in these decisions but quite
often it's really nice to well in this
report it's actually really nice to see
what we've achieved wrapped up in a bow
like everything that we have
accomplished only hear the constant
redirect of our council hasn't done this
or we've stopped that or we've closed
this or that kind of thing but actually
it's a bit of a celebration of where we
are and the things that we do have
planned the things that we are working
to on time and the stuff that we're
actually
just about to open uh given that you
know um icl or we're having the opening
for that is incredible
that didn't even exist
or the idea was really just being
floated around at the start of this term
so it's incredible
thank you councillor
any other comments
councillor lewis and then councillor
abbott only very quick commentary and it
made might well take out one workshop on
induction for the new councillors
it's quite good it's quite expensive
councillor abbott
now my comment would simply be that i
wish that we'd had this sort of
information when i first
commenced in local body politics i think
it's a wonderful wonderful inception and
encourage people to read it and just
make the point that we now have a lot
more information available to the
general public it's over to them to
utilize it
thank you councillor we've had them for
a couple of terms now but i don't think
they've been as easy to follow as this
one
exactly i think the way that it's that
it's laid out is it have been commented
on is really useful mr chair i think so
congratulate congratulations to those
that formatted them thank you councillor
this is hadley uh i think the then
minister of local government uh the
honourable rodney hyde would be very
pleased to hear
the comments and i think that as with
many things it's been an iterative
process we've made a deliberate
decision this year to try and make it
more readable more relatable to engage
with the public from the name of better
democracy
just having a rodney hyde flash back
there
you worship you'll relate with dancing
with the stars yes sir yes
dancing together um
but i think
one of the sort of issues that crops up
at this particular time of the year
is that
it seems we get cr you get credit for
things that you don't really or just may
have started or didn't really even plan
or um
and of course there's recipients that
likewise that um
get benefited or extolled
sort of
kudos
the things they
do don't haven't subscribed all that
willingly to
and it's just one of the laws of the
jungle i guess and it happens every time
there's an election held
that process seems to continue
thank you worship
uh we've had the
two recommendations moved in second and
i'll put that now all in favor
aye against
carried that brings us along to the
activities
report uh i'll go through each section
so who's
who's up first richard
i think the report is read
some highlights just to point out um
just the format of this report we are
doing a little bit of work behind the
scenes so the next time you see this
particular report be a little bit more
consistency with graphs and tables so
we're launching them so as you can
easily
find the information and actually
compare a little bit between them
between graphs because we're all doing a
slightly different approach and it's
time to do a bit of consolidation so
we're working on that
close to year end you'll see the library
is
um
maintaining its own it's apart from the
covered uh bumps and and rises and falls
it would expect it sort of ended up at
the end point of where we would be
within coulee of our target so that's
something really good
another point to notice is that in
the under the museum there would be a
little bit more clarification going
forward between what is the collections
trust the smag operations in terms of
collection and the museum redevelopment
so we're just going to separate that
still providing you with all the
information but it'll just be a bit
clearer for you to find and know
whose information ensues
any questions
counsellors open for questions
uh note in the report that of course
congratulations to the building team
with the irons accreditation
um is anybody actually able to answer a
query that i have with the three thirty
seven thousand in grants went out for
buildings
under the city centre heritage
funding is that up or down on previous
years do you know councillor emerson
[Music]
let me just is that
the
for the earthquake strengthening yes
so that comes through the heritage
equipped funding right now the council
helped um get access to for building
owners across the city thank you
any other questions or comments about
the any of the items in the activities
report
oh just look at my comment it's good to
see that the phone's answered 97.2
times within two minutes it's a lot
different to new zealand which is two
areas
so uh that's very very pleasant yeah
that's a short call i like the 30 second
ones
thank you councillor arnold
there are no other comments i'll look
for somebody to move that we will
receive the report
counselor edmondson councillor lewis
i'll put that all in favor all right
uh there being no other items in
public i'll move that we go into public
excluded
uh for the reasons it is outlined to
confirm the uh minutes of ppp from june
14.
secondly
before you do that you sorry counselor
i just wanted under general business and
um
the
information we had from a rodney tribe
is that going to be addressed
about
what sorry
well he sent us all an email um i can't
quite access it at the moment because
i'm not on extra right sorry so
relevant it's not actually an agenda
item counselor but if you want to raise
it with the chief executive she's happy
to provide you with some clarification
around it
okay right um comments
welcome councillor cracker um may have
actually it's just just general business
as well but may have actually a question
could have sat under the activities
report i um wondered if we would have
any uh
perhaps
steve's here but if we have any idea
of the numbers that came through for the
re-opening of the poll
yeah so we will get some numbers on that
but the anecdotal thing uh observation
was incredibly well supported there were
lines out the door
the finance for the first week was uh
through the roof a huge quantum of uh
memberships which we won't know the full
impact of that because it'll be a lot of
people just renewing normally so it
won't be till next year that we get a
comparison but and it actually looks
really really good and we'll be able to
have some firm figures in the next
report that you see but all in all we're
really pleased with the response and the
people that came
thank you
thanks council you're right that could
have come under the activities report
just remember the
items of general business need to be
raised first yeah so back to the going
into public excluded i'm happy to move
for the reasons as outlined if there's a
second second
councillor sopa thank you i'll put that
all in favor
against carrie thank you to those who've
joined us on the live stream